SO, HURRICANE ETA IS CAUSING
CATASTROPHIC DAMAGE IN FORT
MYERS, AND TONIGHT, THE MAYOR
SAYING UPWARDS OF 200 PEOPLE
RESCUED BY THE FIRE DEPARTMENT,
AND THAT SEARCH AND RESCUE
OPERATION APPEARS TO HAVE COME
TO AN END.
AND DESPITE THE EXTENT OF THE
DESTRUCTION, THE MAYOR SAYS
THAT FORT MYERS IS NOT
REPORTING ANY FATALITIES.
CNN'S RANDI KAYE IS THERE FOR
US.
RANDI?
>> HEY, DON, IF YOU WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THE POWER OF THIS
HURRICANE AND THE POWER OF THIS
STORM IN THE FORT MYERS AREA,
WE HAVE A PERFECT EXAMPLE FOR
YOU.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT YARD.
LET ME JUST SAY THAT UP FRONT.
THIS BOAT THOUGH IS NOW ON DRY
LAND.
CARRIED OVER FROM LEGACY HARBOR,
WHICH IS JUST ON THE OTHER SIDE
OF WHERE WE'RE STANDING, THAT'S
WHERE THE WATER IS, CARRIED
OVER HERE BY THE FORCE OF THE
WINDS, THE WATER, IN THE STORM.
NOT ONLY THAT, BUT YOU ALSO
HAVE THIS MASSIVE PIECE OF
CONCRETE HERE, THIS IS PART OF
THE DOCK.
THIS IS NOT SUPPOSED TO BE
HERE.
IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE WELL ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF US.
BACK IN THE WATER.
BUT WAS ALSO CARRIED OVER HERE.
THIS IS INCREDIBLY HEAVY.
YOU CAN ONLY IMAGINE.
IF YOU LOOK OUT THERE IN THE
DISTANCE, THERE'S SOME MORE
VOTES.
NOT SUPPOSED TO BE HERE.
COMPLETELY OUT OF PLACE.
THERE'S MAYBE ONE, TWO, THREE,
FOUR, 56 BOTH OUT THERE.
ALL SMASHED TOGETHER.
DEFINITELY NOT SUPPOSED TO BE
HERE, CARRIED HERE BY THE STORM
ALONG WITH OTHER PIECES OF THE
DOCK.
THERE'S A COUPLE OF OARS
SCATTERED AROUND, OTHER
MISCELLANEOUS PIECES OF BOATS.
AND THEN, IF YOU JUST GO OVER
HERE, I WANT TO SHOW YOU
SOMETHING REALLY INTERESTING.
THIS RIGHT HERE, THIS IS
ANOTHER BOAT, OF COURSE ON THAT
SIDE, THIS IS THE BOAT LINE.
IF YOU FOLLOW THIS BOATS LINE
IT GOES ALL THE WAY OVER HERE,
IT TOOK, THIS IS A PIECE OF
DOCK, IT'S STILL ATTACHED TO IT
STOP.
THIS BOAT CARRIED ITS OWN DARK
THROUGH THE WIND THROUGH THE
STORM SURGE OVER TO DRY LAND.
SO, IF YOU COME WITH ME, I GET
MY PHOTOGRAPHER TO COME OVER
HERE, GREAT UP, AS WE WALK DOWN
HERE, I JUST WANT YOU TO KNOW
WE'RE ONLY LOOKING TO TALK WITH
SOME OF THE BOAT OWNERS, THEY
APPARENTLY LIVE ON SOME OF
THESE BOATS OR LIVED ON THEM.
AND ARE COMPLETELY DISTRAUGHT,
BECAUSE THIS WAS THEIR HOME,
THIS WAS THEIR LIVELIHOOD LIKE
SO MANY OTHER PEOPLE, IN THIS
STORM THEY LOST EVERYTHING THEY
HAD.
AND NOW THEY'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO PUT IT BACK
TOGETHER.
IF YOU LOOK AT THIS RIGHT HERE,
THIS IS THE OTHER SIDE OF THAT
BOAT, AND A SORT OF MAKESHIFT
BOAT YARD NOW.
YOU CAN IMAGINE THE FORCE OF
THE WATER IN THE WINDS THAT
THAT COULD CARRY THIS SIZE OF A
BOAT HERE AND DO THIS MUCH
DAMAGE TO IT, DON.
IT IS JUST INCREDIBLE TO SEE IT
UP CLOSE AND IMAGINE THE FORCE
OF THOSE WINDS IS JUST
ABSOLUTELY REMARKABLE, DON.
BACK TO YOU.
>> NO DOUBT, RANDI KAYE, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE
THAT.
LET'S BRING IN NOW SCOTT CARLOS,
WHO RODE OUT THE HURRICANE IN
FORT MYERS.
SCOTT, APPRECIATE YOU JOINING
US, I WANT TO KNOW HOW YOU'RE
DOING SINCE YOU RODE OUT THE
STORM, IN YOUR FOURTH STORY
CONDO IN FORT MYERS BEACH.
WHAT WAS IT LIKE.
WHAT DO YOU SEE OUT THE WINDOWS?
>> YES, EVERYTHING IS JUST A
BUNCH OF DEBRIS FIELDS, AND
SAND EVERYTHING.
A LOT OF THE ROADS BROKEN AWAY
AS WELL.
ALONG WITH ALL THE HOUSES ARE
JUST COMPLETELY DEMOLISHED.
>> YOU SAW WATER RISE OVER YOUR
NEIGHBORS HOUSES, SO TELL ME
ABOUT THAT.
HOW HIGH DO YOU THINK IT GOT?
>> I WOULD SAY AT LEAST TEN
FEET HIGH, SO LOOKING ACROSS
THE WAY WE WATCHED THE WATER
WITH THE WAVES CRASHING AGAINST
THE HOMES GUTTER SYSTEMS UP TOP,
IT SMASHED THROUGH THE ACTUAL
ROOF.
IT HAD TO HAVE BEEN ANYWHERE
FROM 9 TO 10 FEET ACROSS THE
STREET FROM US.
AND WE'RE 300 YARDS OFF THE
WATER OURSELVES, WITH OUR --
VERY LONG.
>> I UNDERSTAND THAT YOU HAVE
HURRICANE BLASTED YOUR CONDO,
THAT'S FOR STORIES UP, WAS THAT
ENOUGH PROTECTION FOR YOU?
YOU SAID THE WATER STILL SEEPED
THROUGH THE BUILDING?
>> CORRECT, YES, SO WITH THE
PRESSURE AND EVERY TIME THE
WAVES HIT, IT WAS FORCING WATER
THROUGH LIKE THE CRACKS OF THE
SLIDING GLASS DOORS, AND EVEN
THE WINDOWS IN THE BEDROOMS AS
WELL.
WE HAD TO KEEP PUTTING TOWELS
UP AND JUST THE PRESSURE WHICH
IS PUSHING THE WATER INTO THE
CONDO, SO I CAN IMAGINE ALL THE
HOMEOWNERS AS WELL WHAT THEY
WERE GOING THROUGH.
>> YOU KNOW, YOU'VE BEEN RIDING
SCOOTERS THROUGH THE STREETS,
YOU'VE BEEN HELPING PEOPLE,
YOU'VE BEEN WATCHING THE COAST
GUARD PICK UP PEOPLE.
TELL ME WHAT YOU'VE SEEN, AND
WHAT IS IT LIKE OUTSIDE?
>> SO, JUST KIND OF WALKING
AROUND, AND RIDING AROUND WE
SAW --
WE SAW TWO OR THREE HOMES THAT
WERE RIPPED FROM THEIR
FOUNDATIONS.
--
SITTING IN THE MIDDLE THE
STREET, IN FORT MYERS BEACH.
IT WAS PRETTY WELL.
>> YOU'VE ALSO SEEN HELICOPTER
RESCUES, CAN YOU TELL ME ABOUT
THAT?
>> YES, SO THERE IS A WOMAN WHO
APPROACHED US FOR HELP, AND
THERE WAS ANYTHING WE CAN DO,
LUCKILY EVERYONE IS ABLE TO
FLIP DOWN THE COAST GUARD,
WHICH CIRCLE AROUND ONE TIME
AND LANDED DIRECTLY ON THE
BEACH, NOT EVEN 100 FEET FOR US,
WE WATCHED THE WHOLE THING.
AND HE HAD HELPED HER OUT.
HE PICKED HER UP AND CARRIED
HER AWAY.
AND THEN WE WATCHED ANOTHER
RESCUE WHERE THEY PICKED UP TWO
PEOPLE IN STRETCHERS WITH THE
HOOKS AND EVERYTHING AND PULL
THEM UP AS WELL.
THEY WERE WORKING NIGHT AND DAY
NONSTOP.
>> WELL, MY GOODNESS.
I'M SURE PEOPLE ARE WONDERING
WHY YOU STAYED, BUT AS I
UNDERSTAND, YOU CAME TO CHECK
ON YOUR CONDO.
AND YOU DECIDED TO STAY.
YOU DIDN'T THINK THE STORM
WOULD BE THIS BAD.
WOULD YOU HAVE STAYED IF YOU
HAD KNOWN?
>> DEFINITELY NOT.
NOW THAT WE'RE STUCK HERE, NOW
THAT WE ACTUALLY SAW THE
SITUATION WAS CREATED BY THIS,
THE FAMILY BACK HOME AND STUFF,
NOT BEING ABLE TO GUIDE THEM
THROUGH THAT.
LUCKILY DIDN'T LOSE TOO MUCH
STUFF.
I CAN BE ABLE TO KEEP TIME WITH
HIM --
IF I DID OVER, JEN NO, I
DEFINITELY WOULD NOT COME BACK.
>> YOU'RE FROM THE MIDWEST, I
DOUBT THAT YOU'VE EVER SEEN
ANYTHING LIKE THIS, YOU
PROBABLY HAVE TO DEAL WITH
TORNADOES IN SUCH REVERSING
ANYTHING LIKE THIS?
>> NOTHING EVEN CLOSE TO THAT.
BACK HOME, WE GET THE RAIN, --
WE MIGHT JUMP ON A KAYAK AND
HAVE FUN, BUT THERE'S NO DANGER
INVOLVED.
SO, THIS WAS DEFINITELY A
DANGEROUS AND SOMETHING ALL
NEVER FORGET.
>> YEAH, LISTEN, WE'RE GLAD
THAT YOU'RE OKAY, AND WE WERE
GLAD THAT YOU'RE FAMILIE